no mercy reiser on va retrouver
maintenant cabu qui est dans un autre
style aussi un dessinateur journalistes
c'est ça alors déjà je crois qu'on va
tout de suite voir en images à travers
une sorte de petit reportage simulation
la méthode de travail de cabu et vous
allez voir finalement il fait à peu près
comme nous nous faisons chacun dans
notre métier quand on veut raconter un
événement raconter une histoire
vous connaissez sur l'isle doubs
canard que mon boss elite temps en temps
pour quoi alors
quand tu arrives je veux dire vous
intéresser à l'étalement des vacances
totalement des vacances alors justement
on m'a dit que vous étiez parti avec un
chien et que vous êtes preuve du sens
chien tu fus vous raconter ça à les
voisins pas vous attacher à ces trucs là
les ragots de couloir le voyant est
violée en plus quand mon chien il
aboyait au revoir monsieur je dois
encore vous savez je suis avec la
télévision là parce qu'on fait un
reportage que les quelques centaines de
et si vous ne me répondez pas on verra
on verra à la télévision que vous voulez
pas me répondre je vous demande
simplement deux minutes oui mais alors
pas de photo à ses côtés on vous verra
de dos ou alors avec un bandeau sur les
yeux sur les os ciblera les ige pas dans
l'agir est carrément comment vous avez
fait pour abandonner votre chien ce que
vous l'avez accroché à un arbre possible
vous rendez pas compte
pas du tout absolument pas monsieur que
ce qui plaît à raconter ça je vous dis
les voisins disent que chacun
effectivement échec
j'ai perdu mon dieu on s'est arrêté pour
aller pisser et puis l'air on l'a pas
retrouvée impossible impossible de le
retrouver
bon eh qu'est ce que vous pensez des
gens qui abandonnent leurs chiens tracé
du salon monsieur ça les [ __ ] jamais
je fais ça c'est déjà assez triste de le
perdre mais jamais je ne m'entraîne
jamais croyons-nous ce qui est à 300
mille par an
ces trois cent mille de trop voilà qu'à
but c'est exactement
illustration de ce que vous faites
pratiquement toutes les semaines dans
charlie hebdo et qu'on retrouve ici
voilà le reportage dessiné donc que l'on
vient de voir à la télévision en ce
moment c'est exactement ce que ce que
vous faites chaque semaine oui c'est à
dire c'est l'électeur souvent qui qui
nous écrivent au journal pour nous
indiquer des reportages à faire vous
vous passer peut-être par les agences de
presse nous nous avons des rations peu
privilégié avec nos lecteurs
alors ce jour là c'était un électeur qui
m'avait dit dans l'immeuble il ya un
chien qui a un maître en beau donner son
chien et non pas le contraire
et ça c'est vraiment une information
c'est l'heure bernard brault qui disait
ça alors j'y suis allée comme ça au
culot quoi
j'avais emmené à la télé dans non mais
chaque fois que je le revois je peux pas
empêcher de rigoler parce que c'est
vraiment un
ce qu'on appelle un beau c'est à dire un
type qui y doute pas lui là il ya que
des certitudes voyez c'est ça les mois
mais qui travaillait dans le temps
c'était des gens comme ça que vous avez
à l'épaule oui peut changer le spectacle
à au figaro ah oui oui mais il y en a
partout même les bof c'est aussi c'est
aussi moi aussi on a tous une part une
part de bof quoi la définition du beauf
cabu c'est quoi exactement
je vous dis c'est le type qui qui
assènent des vérités sévérité
il réfléchit absolument paris il est
porté par des part les lieux communs par
par le bon sens par entre guillemets par
des certitudes dont ils ne démordent
ceux des mandants
j'avais donc ne demandera jamais pays il
est entretenu je crois que
il y plus d'abord il est plus de
journaux
c'est sûr que c'est la mort du papier
alors il ya que le papier je crois le
papier surtout privilégier la réflexion
alors que maintenant les images
les images tout seul
constituent
empêche toute réflexion tu vois la
télévision en particulier oui si avec la
télévision c'est sur le papier aussi
avec losier en particulier jacques
laurent josi est bon c'est un autre
style de reportage c'est un peu ce que
l'on pourrait peut-être appelé je crois
les